join my day Joe Rogan podcast by night
all day in your opinion what happened to
the young girl that was Ronda Rousey yes
The Olympian girl that you know all of a
sudden went from the penthouse to the
[ __ ] a lot of things it's a long
long when I was a big follower her
amazing judo practitioner and dominant
like no one else ever in women's and I
may come to that point in the UFC at
least but there was some holes in her
approach that were exposed by Holly Holm
knocked around girl head kicked her yeah
Holly had the perfect style to deal with
Ronda style she's really strong she's
fast amazing athlete and she is an
outstanding striker and so Ronda thing
was to charge at you like a [ __ ] bull
and Holly just played the matador
brilliantly caught her lit her up while
she was coming in and then eventually
had kicked her and stopped her once you
get knocked out like that first of all
she was very very confident while she
was the champion and some people would
say arrogant and because of that there's
always people that are waiting for you
to fall there's a lot of people out
there that don't have much confidence
and when they see someone who's out
there who's got a lot of confidence it's
very compelling like a Floyd Mayweather
or London Conor McGregor their
confidence is incredibly compelling like
you want to be near them you would but
those people when that person loses
they're the first ones to attack they're
like yeah you [ __ ] lose or I knew you
were losing like you go to Ronda
Rousey's Instagram page and read the
comments under her pictures it's
ruthless some [ __ ] [ __ ] this
[ __ ] and I guarantee you all those
people are severely unaccomplished know
or really young either young kids that
don't understand what they're doing they
just have this opportunity to be able to
talk [ __ ] or they're a bunch of [ __ ]
losers and they're finding this
opportunity to [ __ ] on someone who was
this incredible bright shining star that
fizzled out so she lost to Holly Holm
and then she came back in a far worse
matchup against Amanda Nunez and I
thought Nunez before Holly Holm beater I
thought Nunez was the most dangerous
matchup for because Amanda Nunez is a
Brazilian jiu-jitsu blackbelt and she's
heavy heavy hands she's a dangerous
striker
I don't think Rhonda's gonna have to
close the distance sort of grab her
take it to the ground when she does some
[ __ ] picnic because Amanda Nunez is
nasty on the ground and then getting
close to her she's got knockout power
with her hands like this is a terrible
terrible matchup and turned out to be
right because she got knocked out in 48
seconds in the rematch but what she
should have done is revamp or camp or
not fight revamp we go to one of the
Masters there's a few masters of mixed
martial arts in this world is for us a
hobby and Matt Hume and Duke Rufus a few
these striking mixed martial arts
masters and you have to go to them you
have to go to them and you have to like
submit yourself and say look let's fix
this let's fix whatever I'm doing and
let's see if we can take this to the
next level because the sport evolved and
the sport passed her by
she was at the very top but if you build
it like that Field of Dreams movie you
build it they will come and when she
built the women's bantamweight division
and became this dominant force and
stopped all these people and looked
invincible all those women were coming
up below her and they were they were
getting better and they were evolving
and they were like the rest of MMA they
were reaching this incredibly high level
whereas the women's MMA movement and
then in the early days you know three
four years ago if you watched women's
MMA the skill level was nowhere near
commensurate with the men's skill level
add immense skill level at three four
years ago they're better today but only
a little bit better but the women are
way better today than they were because
it's a new thing it's like 1997 for
mixed martial arts for men that's what
like three or four years ago was but now
the women have essentially pretty much
caught up or close to it there's very
high-level striking very high level
submissions very high level fluid
overall mixed martial arts games that
you're seeing in the women's division
and Ronda in a lot of ways a spectacular
she was had a very limited approach she
didn't kick she punched but she wasn't
necessarily like the most brutal
knockout puncher and she wasn't
necessarily the most skillful boxer she
didn't really have a tremendous amount
of experience what she had was
incredible athleticism a world-class
mindset she was a world-class athlete
you know she's a former Olympian and
outstanding judo her judo and her arm
bars are amongst the best in the world
I'm sure transitions
Jewish attacks and attacks and tax and
set things up she's phenomenally
talented and and you know really
accomplished in judo but when you want
to be a world mixed martial arts
champion at the highest level of the
game now you have to be great at
everything there's people like Demetrius
Mighty Mouse Johnson who I think is over
the world he's amazing yeah that guy's
great at everything and that's why he's
the best because you don't know what the
[ __ ] he's going to do you don't know if
he's gonna kick you or knee or take you
down or strangle you or elbow you he's
just got so many options and he's coming
at you from all different directions and
he never gets tired he's he's a total
full package we don't have a Demetrius
Mighty Mouse Johnson and women's MMA yet
but it's coming it's coming
and bran does not that you know Ronda is
more like maybe like a Chuck Liddell or
one of the early pioneers of men's MMA
super talented really fun to watch but
perhaps limited in their approach you
know I used to I enjoy my team as now
that you mentioned is incredible it's
incredible you know and there's there's
so many of them now I mean it's just
this sport is just exploding
[Applause]
[Music]